[dramatic music]
BEAR GRYLLS: Anthony Mackie
and I are high in the Dolomite
Mountains of Italy.
Doing a great job
Anthony, well done.
We're using an old
hemp rope, just
like soldiers would
use in World War I,
to descend the sheer rock face.
It's about now I
reckon Anthony's
wishing he had his falcon
wings at his beck and call.
How are you doing Anthony?
[breathing hard]
I'm good.
BEAR GRYLLS: You're
getting there.
You're like, halfway, now.
Aw, man.
There's this great wall--
there's no footing on this wall!
BEAR GRYLLS: Keep going!
I've still got you on
this line, so you're good.
OK.
Come on.
[grunts with effort]
Argh.
There's nothing here, Bear.
OK, do you want me
to come down to you?
Let me come and join you.
No, I do not want you
on this rope with me.
OK.
Last bit.
Walk it out.
Climb it down.
Come on, Anthony.
Come on.
Just got to make
it to right there.
Right there.
Come on, Anthony.
Come on.
[nervous sounds]
Oh, [bleep].
[grunting with effort]
[sigh]
Whoo-hoo!
Great job, Anthony!
Smashed it!
I hate you, Bear.
OK, here we go.
That was really scary.
When I first went over the wall,
I thought I was going to fall.
Smash into the rocks.
Then, I kind of just
wanted to tuck into a ball
and roll down that cavern
and smash into the rocks.
But I really wanted to
do it, so my sons could
see me doing something crazy.
And I made it down.
I did it!
Good job here, Anthony.
Yo.
That's more-- it's more
awkward than it looks,
isn't it?
Maybe we kind of just tuck
down on the edge, there.
OK.
I never want to do that again.
No, you will never
have to do that again.
That was clearly
tough for Anthony,
and underneath
the fatigue, I can
tell that he's so
proud of himself
for making it down the mountain.
Let's take two minutes,
have a little drink.
So, yeah, a little recovery.
But good job.
That was intense.